latest pictures emerging not sure which
day but so they attack clearly still
going on there's the first time you know
I've seen these pictures but you just
see that that terror that is happening
there that's Gerry security guard
probably the back and the woman and
covering their child I mean that that's
shocking
the shocking image that looks very much
like the cafeteria doesn't it probably
on the set of the other Sunday
okay I don't know if that is a security
I but that could be a family that
there's someone shouting at them this is
the first time we're seeing his pictures
by the way that poor girl look at the
top right there's just evidence there's
some blood on the floor yes
and this is obviously an interlude of a
firing
a warning for petting one just really
joining us some of these pictures could
be distressing we've screened them first
for violence but they're pretty
distressing seeing that then that is
that same girl I think it is the same
family
escaping successfully but a real insight
him you know we've been supporting for
the last four days on what had happened
in there and just that sense of terror
confusion yeah well there was a moment
in there I mean it's only a brief 60
seconds but there's a moment with that
young girl and that red looks up and and
there's just this absolute fear and
bewilderment on her face which really
captured and you know how awful it was
and also just just what happened to
ordinary people
caught up in it nothing to do with
whatever it is that al-shabaab want
which is Kenyan troops out a territory
that their country but yeah the girl we
can't see her now she's hidden by the
county but at the moment Island security
go or a bystander or her father picks
her up and the look on her face is just
one of terror and balloon